ladies and gentlemen I wish you welcome
to the economics lecture which is held
by this year's laureate in economics
professor Angus Deaton and you see you
will see him alive in a moment you see
his cartoon there where he looks at the
earth in a microscope and it's sort of
meant to convey the image that he has
been studying consumption in different
perspectives the large very large
picture of macroeconomic consumption and
the very small picture of individual
consumers decisions individual
households decisions to consume you will
hear more about it during the lecture
I'm sure and let's look at the official
motivation for the price which reads for
his analysis of consumption poverty and
Welfare and a few biographical details
he was he grew up in Edinburgh in
Scotland studied and got his PhD in
Cambridge England and now he lives in
Princeton the United States and I think
I shouldn't say anything more so I just
wish you welcome professor Deaton please
enter the stage
thanks so much
thank you so much it's a true wonder to
be here and I'm enormous ly grateful for
this award and today I'm going to talk a
little bit about some of the work I did
that was cited in the award so I'm going
to talk about behavior a welfare and
poverty there are some themes that I
want to highlight from the beginning one
of them is perhaps the overriding thing
that gains that has guided a tremendous
amount of my work over the years which
is inquiring into policy that makes
people people better off that can
improve well-being if you think about
this in the context of global poverty
for example the problem here I think is
not that there's any lack of tools and
policies there are many many policies
out there for whom advocates believe
that they can make the world a better
place but the key thing here is using
measurement as honest scorekeeping to
find out whether something is actually
working or whether it's not working at
all and one of the themes I'll emphasize
throughout is the enormous importance of
measurement almost by itself we're
always told there's no measurement
without theory and while that's true
it's more true just to say that
measurement is incredibly important and
it's often forgotten in economics just
how important measurement is the other
theme I'm going to talk about throughout
is individuals versus aggregates or
averages in a world in which you work
entirely on averages if you look at the
macro economy things like inequality and
poverty are simply not legible without
disaggregation without the details of
individuals the other thing is even if
you're only interested in the aggregate
me distribution clearly matters for
aggregate economic activity and
certainly for any serious analysis of
well-being finally we know that behavior
and well-being are linked for
individuals they're not linked for
aggregate so what you see from the
macroeconomy doesn't necessarily tell
you by itself whether people are doing
better or doing worse there's a theme
which runs through a lot of my work in
which is being challenged and I'm
sympathetic to that challenge which is
that if people by and large behave in
their own interests than by looking at
their behavior we can infer quite a lot
about how they are doing
it's what economists called revealed
preference analysis and it's always been
long been the standard in economics I'm
going to start at the very oldest stuff
and come up to stuff I've been doing
relatively recently and then move back
more chronologically so starting with
household surveys surveys which inquired
into people's living standards started
in the 18th century late in the 18th
century and have always been used then
and now as measurement for social
monitoring and for activism the idea
being to find out how ordinary people
live and by documenting how ordinary the
people live to bring that to the
attention of the ruling classes often to
shock them with the terrible living
standards of the poor and to shock those
people into trying doing something so
measurement as part of activism has been
very important dollar-a-day poverty
measures do the same thing today as do
data on infant mortality and stunting
and wasting in children children this
sort of simple documentation is not just
for poor countries I mean in rich
countries today we all know about
stagnant or falling real median wages
over time in the United States and in
some other countries the incredible
rises in income inequality that have
been taken place throughout many rich
countries and occasional rising
mortality rates for using mortality
rates as some sort of key for what's
happening to the population another
application that runs particularly in
poor countries is in aggregate
cultural households just documenting
whether these people are not pursue MERS
or net producers of staple foods like
rice or wheat
can tell you a lot to the first order
about whether they're harmed or herded
by agricultural policy or by tariff
changes and these are again examples of
measurements they're just unbelievably
important in their own right and take
you a long way towards thinking about
policy one of the most famous things of
course is the analysis of household
budgets going back to Ernst Engel in the
19th century looked at the food share
and noticed that richer households spent
a smaller share of their budget on food
and poorer households and there's been a
long subsequent literature trying to use
that as an indicator of welfare another
theme in that literature is looking at
how children alter the consumption
patterns of households and underlying
that has been a theme of trying to
measure the costs of children whatever
that means there's been a very difficult
area another issue that I worked on is
whether budgets are different if the
kids or girls or if the kids are boys if
you hold everything else constant and in
my work and in several other
replications people have actually find
it surprisingly hard to find evidence of
discrimination that way even when you
see the discrimination in society as a
whole another issue which i think is of
lasting importance and has been much
highlighted recently is why in spite of
rapid economic growth in India is per
capita calorie consumption falling in
spite of the mass malnourishment
especially among kids that exists in
India you would expect in a rapidly
growing economy with much malnourishment
the calorie consumption would be rising
rapidly in fact it's falling we don't
again really know why that happens
how do budget patterns change as the
household becomes larger and again
there's some major puzzles of there on
this I wanted to highlight India many of
these questions I've great importance
for India much of the work has been done
on Indian data
and India was really the home of
probability sampling when Mahalanobis
started crop surveys in the 1930s and
1940s and funded the National Sample
Survey organization which has played a
large role in this analysis including in
my work one of the things you'd like to
know with surveys is you want to know
how people respond to prices and I'm
going to talk about that quite a bit
normally you can't do that from surveys
but some surveys collect data on
quantities as well as expenditures so
you know for a household that they
bought three kilos of rice and paid so
much for it over the last week so you
can get some idea of how much they paid
for each kilo and you can use that to
analyze responses to prices across
different space one of the interesting
things about that work is it tends to
show these spatial price responses tend
to be quite large suggesting that
long-run responses which is what you're
perhaps picking up in across space are
larger than short-run responses this is
important because it suggests that the
short run policy response the short run
price response that we usually model may
greatly underestimate the distortions
which policy might cause em in the long
run I wanted to highlight two some open
issues here one is in these household
survey data the quality of the data are
often not up to the task which is put to
them this is particularly true in Africa
but not always in Africa there's also
wide spread throughout the world and
perhaps its worst in India a conflict
between the data that comes from the
National Accounts and the data that come
from the household surveys and so in
India the growth that everyone is so
very proud of in GDP per capita really
does not show up to anything like the
same extent in the household surveys
this really means that you cannot have a
coherent discussion about well-being
inequality and poverty in India because
the two sources of data for which you'd
be able to connect up growth with
poverty and inequality are mutually
inconsistent and you really can't see
anything sensible and then what happens
is each political side picks its own
database
and they go to a completely fruitless
war talking against each other and the
data never get improved India is perhaps
the worst case here but these problems
exist really widely throughout the world
I wanted to say a few words about
international comparisons because if
you're going to compute global poverty
or look at the state of the world's poor
you've got to have some method of
comparable making comparable
measurements across different countries
with different currencies and different
consumption patterns one of the greatest
intellectual achievements in measurement
over the last 50 years is the
International comparison program which
was begun at Penn by Cravath summers in
Hesston Allan Houston is sitting in the
front row here in 1968 it's an enormous
achievement which sadly has never been
recognized here in the way that it
should have been the ICP is still very
active both in measurement and
conceptual advances and indeed there
remain very large challenges and it's I
also find it a little sad that
relatively few economists work on this
in spite of the enormous intellectual
challenges that there are there to do it
so let me move on to some of the earlier
work I did on analyzing consumption
patterns in the 1960s and 70s demand
analysis as it's called the study of
consumption patterns was concerned with
using aggregate data to fit the
quantities consumed to prices to data on
prices and income I came to Cambridge to
the Cambridge growth model as a research
assistant in the late 1960s and I was
asked to look after the demand system
estimation and to think about
consumption and saving in the growth
model this was a project headed by
Richard stone who was the Nobel laureate
in 1984 that was the impetus for much
that I did subsequently or indeed if you
were being unkind you should think that
I was given this task as an RA and I'm
still working on it
almost 50 years later having never found
anything better to do
or at least I find lots of fascinating
things to do there when I showed up in
1969 stones linear expenditure system
was used as part of the growth model
it's a very simple case of additive
preferences which without going into
that in detail what it does is it gives
you a very tight link between the way
demands respond to income and the way
that demands respond to prices now think
of 1969 1970 we were working with about
18 annual observations instead of the
millions millions of observations we
have today so having a very restricted
tight specification like this was
extremely useful in fact as probably all
you could have done in those days but
and I remember this troubling me from
the very beginning when I worked on this
that we were basically assuming answers
that we ought to be measuring them and I
always find that extremely troubling so
we needed more general but still
tractable models I was also worried from
the very beginning about the nature of
the representative agent assumption that
was built into these models that we were
pretending there was one single person
who is behaving for the whole aggregate
economy so how did that come about well
it turned out that a lot of the results
were actually known at that time and
turns Gorman who played a very important
part in my life had proved the results
on aggregation / Goods and aggregation /
people he proved these results in papers
in the 1950s and 1960s the trouble is
these papers use the dual representation
of preferences in which you think of
well-being is defined by prices and
incomes rather than by quantities and if
you grown up studying conventional
economics those papers were incredibly
hard to read at that time they don't
seem so hard now and I remember going
off to try to read those papers locking
myself in a room for a week and I was
determined that I would not come out of
the room until I'd really understood
what that paper was about and I came out
at the end of the week and I knew
absolutely no more than I did
at the beginning of the week but slowly
there began to be a little bit of
understanding dan McFadden at the same
time I had realized these results were
known to theorists but there were
relatively few people of which Gorman
and McFadden were the most notable who
had understood that this dual
representation was really the way to
derive theoretically consistent demands
that were analytically convenient for
actually adapting and studying the data
so that was the the major breakthrough
that those two guys understood and not
too many other people at the time did
now Johnny Ober is sitting here too and
I'm going to talk a little bit about him
John came back to the UK from doing a
PhD in Berkeley in 1969 um he had been
advised by Bob Hall I recently asked Bob
Hall you know where did your lecture
notes come from he said I just stole
them from Dan McFadden so you know Dan
McFadden was sort of behind a lot of
this at the time and then had these
wonderful lecture notes on consumer and
producer theory using duality which I
remember became a sort of Bible again
you people today cannot imagine how the
world was before the web and when people
had written these incredibly important
papers but never published them and
getting a hold of them was unbelievably
difficult you almost had to send rescue
squads and to find these papers and
steal them and bring them but when John
came back from Berkeley we met each
other and we realized that we knew a lot
of the same material that was otherwise
not so very well known and we decided
that it was a really good thing to pull
what we knew and explain our newfound
knowledge to the world as a whole a very
arrogant thing for two kids in their 20
year olds to do but that eventually
turned into our joint text on economics
and consumer behavior now at the same
time we wanted to get away from the
problems with a model like the linear
expenditure system and built a better
tool for analyzing demand and so we
spent I think probably a year and a half
or so tinkering and fiddling trying to
find a real
good a perfect demand system much of
this was based on Jamil bars earlier
work on irrigation on a functional form
another important thread on this was our
Wendy words work on flexible functional
forms which broke this very tight
restriction and allowed you to fit
something that was about as general as
could possibly be hanging you handled so
we tinkered with these dual
representations to get a convenient easy
to estimate demand system we almost got
everything we wanted and that was why it
was called the almost ideal Tran system
and it still remains very widely used
today it's certainly not a perfect model
but one of the things it did that had
not been done in these demands before
was it got away from the representative
agent at least to the point where an
equality played a role in the pattern of
the demand in a serious way and that was
really the contribution of John's work
on irrigation came to its fruition in
this joint work that we did together so
let me move on from the consumer demand
to enter temporal choice which was the
third area that the committee had
identified and talk about saving first
there were two papers famous papers
written by Franco Modigliani and Richard
Brum Brum Berg do is I think a graduate
student at the time that were written in
the 1950s only one of which was
published in an edited volume and the
other one was available then I remember
reading it even when I was an
undergraduate in Cambridge in the
library Bromberg died very very young
and I think Franco Modigliani never
really had the heart to publish that
paper so once again it remained a sort
of secret document when I read those two
papers to me it was a revelation of how
I wanted to do economics and really
shaped a lot of what I've tried to do
ever since these models have this very
clear very simple theoretical structure
in which the life cycle is modeled they
give you a way of
thinking about an issue of enormous
importance for understanding the
well-being of people and for
understanding public policy almost
anything to do with savings and pensions
for instance you have to think about it
in some form like this the other thing
that impressed me enormous ly about
those papers was when they were written
a lot of people had worked on savings in
consumption and there was a mass of
results mutually contradictory results
from cross-section time series cross
countries all sorts of stuff and no one
understood how it hung together or any
coherent sense and those papers
systematically said here is the story
which can actually reconcile a huge
amount of this evidence so it gives you
a lens in which suddenly everything came
into focus and you could figure out what
was actually going on the other thing
that appealed to me down and appeals to
me now and I'd love to tell non
economist about this when they say what
is economics ever done that's not
obvious in the life cycle hypothesis
each person doesn't do any savings over
the life cycle the simplest version at
least because they cumulate wealth when
they're young and they spend it when
they're old and so their net savings
over their life cycle is nothing and you
might say well how can that explain an
economy in which there's not savings and
what medical eonni realized was that in
a growing economy the young people were
savings on a larger scale than the
elderly were dis saving and therefore
when you aggregate it up to the economy
as a whole you got a completely
different result from the individual
behavior in which rate of growth effects
produced the savings rates I mean this
is really wonderful this is the opposite
of a representative agent and it's not
just thinking about aggregation as being
a nuisance to be gotten rid of it's
actually a positive force for coming out
and understanding the world and I this
to me was an enormous revelation and one
of the sadder things what my later wife
is life is the work that Chris Paxson I
did in which we pretty much convinced
ourselves to my great distress that the
story is not right and that you know the
evidence can be hard even to really very
beautiful
pieces of theory
there were also a number of major
innovations in the 1970s and I've been
trying in the last few weeks to trace
this back which was a simultaneous
theory of lifecycle labor supply and
commodity demands and it's clear that
Jim Heckman is Princeton PhD thesis in
1971 was a very important part of this
there was that important work by Becker
Gilbert gas by Hackman and later a very
famous paper by Tom mccurdy this is a
world in which it's realized that inter
temporarily additive preferences can
give you demand systems within each
period of the form that we'd always used
except instead of income
these were linked together by the
marginal utility money which solved
which enforced the life cycle wealth
constraint the thing that was also
beautiful about that formulation was
that it allowed you to incorporate
uncertainty which is something that many
of us were still struggling with
empirically at that time and the
marginal utility wealth evolved this
martingale difference if this model is
sort of working in the right way when we
first started working on that I
developed a method of tracking birth
cohorts through successive independent
household surveys you would really like
to have panel data which is what mccurdy
had used but that's very hard to do and
I developed this tool that in some ways
was not just an inferior substitute but
gave a different way of using data that
were much much more widely available and
had certain advantages to track what was
happening over time I'll come back to
that in the paper with Martin browning
and Martin Irish we were somewhat
skeptical that the model actually
explained anything very much and wages
for instance are humph shaped over the
life cycle they rise in middle age
according to the simple version of the
theory consumption should be much
flatter but it isn't it some shape too
we also find that the business cycle and
life cycle frequencies of consumption
and savings really could not be easily
reconciled now there's been enormous
later work following this up using the
same sort of cohort methods and that
later work has been much more positive
than we
we're though I'm not totally convinced
if only because it's come at a great
cost in terms of simplicity it may of
course also be true as we first thought
that these simple life cycle models are
not true and that people may not be able
to easily borrow and spend as is assumed
in those models so that after doing that
I moved on to thinking about what became
known as buffer stock savings this is a
world in which people can't borrow to
fund their consumption and so they can
only accumulate their own assets and
spend it this again seem particularly
relevant in developing countries where
there were very poor credit markets and
possibly very high interest rates now
Gila rock was also here and I had
started working around the same time on
the mathematically identical model of
commodity prices which have been
developed by Gustafson at the University
of Chicago in their 30s and with a lot
of help from gay I worked on this with
in the consumption context and this is
one of the very few pieces of work in my
life where I've taken what is nowadays
called the dynamic structural approach
to the data and I learned an enormous
amount from that which is why I've
always been fairly sympathetic to this
approach one of the things that these
models produce is that people do not
lived hand-to-mouth they don't simply
spend their income in every period and
although they rarely hit the borrowing
constraint they behave very differently
because of the presence of the budget
constraint constraint so this is a sort
of magic feature of this model that you
put this potential thread in there and
it completely changes people's behavior
even though the threat is never actually
materialized and so that was something I
learned from doing this work that I had
no idea at all and people do say than
this safe to smooth and protect
themselves against the lean years in the
fluctuations in their incomes and
subsequently that model and related
models have become one of the basic
workhorses for thinking about savings
and consumption
another great innovation in the 1970s at
the same time had been Bob Hall's work
and actually I remember in John Leo Barr
bringing me that paper when we were in
Bristol together and saying you've got
to read this paper and Bob had reworked
Friedman's permanent income theory using
rational expectations ideas which were
very new and current at the time and
this this is what is sometimes called
the random walk theory of consumption
and it opened up an enormous subsequent
torrent of research one of the things
that was very useful to me was that
within that framework in very simple
cases it was possible to derive explicit
formulas which told you what the change
in consumption should be when there were
innovations in the stochastic process
driving earnings so if you could model
the stochastic process driving earnings
you got very precise statements about
what should be happening to the
consumption a wonderful thing for an
empiricist to have and to look at but I
was very puzzled when I was doing this
because I thought I'd gone crazy and I
was getting wildly inconsistent
contradictory results and what turned
out there was that if you took what at
that time was the most popular and
plausible stochastic process for
earnings it actually implied that the
permanent income hypothesis had the
opposite implications for why the
permanent income hypothesis had been
invented which was that it predicted
that consumption should not be smoother
than income which it is in the data but
the consumption should be less smooth
than data so it was this here was this
basic theory taught in every textbook
and it actually had the opposite
prediction as to what people had thought
people got very angry with me for
writing that paper and I remember being
shouted at and seminars and told that if
I couldn't do anything better than that
I should go and be a fly fisherman or
something more useful though one counter
example to that was I got a letter which
I really prized at the time from Bob
Solow which started off saying this is a
fan letter and then just told me how
wonderful he thought that paper was so
if someone was on my side of course
there are lots of ways of resolving this
paradox and one of which once again
is to work with individual data and not
work at the aggregate because one of the
things there are many parts of this
resolution but one of the things that is
true is that the stochastic process for
individuals when you aggregate them up
to the economy as a whole completely
change their stochastic property so in
some sense this whole thing was a false
dichotomy but it reinforced once again
that we should be working at the micro
level and not working and aggregates so
the final thing I want to talk about is
the consumption inequality and this is
work I did with Chris Paxson and the
random walk Theory consumption has
another startling implication which is
if you take a bunch of people and you
put them outside the door here of the
aula magna you take a hundred people and
you instruct them to walk off randomly
in all directions and you go away for a
day or two and then you come back they
will be scattered all over Stockholm
even though they started in exactly the
same place and so this even each one of
them is as an increment to their
behavior at any given time that's a
stationary stochastic process you're
generating this non stationary behavior
it's sort of like a people sitting
around the roulette wheel and they start
with all the same stacks but in the end
they finish up some people with big
stacks and some people with small stacks
so this this risk even stationary risk
can be accumulated at the consumption
inequality that wealth inequality
increases even more rapidly than
consumption inequality unless of course
there's some offset for instance from
insurance arrangements in society that
tie together people's earnings or tie
together the consumption independently
of their earnings and so you can use the
spread of consumption over time to
assess the degree to which society is
actually ensuring its members a sort of
very important idea in economics as to
what extent societies to insure their
members against the ravages of luck
Chris Paxson and I find that in several
countries we looked at the data behaved
in the way that we predicted which of
course is subject to what
think of as poppers curse you know
coppers that popper says that if you
reject a hypothesis you learn something
of course you're much more pleased if
you confirm your hypothesis if no one's
looked at that before but poppers curse
is that someone else will think up of
another explanation for that and it
doesn't prove your theories right at all
nevertheless these ideas they're
spreading inequality and the matching of
these higher moments of consumption to
the data have become a sort of central
idea in what is called heterogeneous
agent macroeconomics today and the
modeling of the stochastic process of
earnings is a very central area - now in
the brief I was given I was told to talk
about my discoveries I think they
probably send this text to everybody and
it's not entirely clear whether
economists are supposed to have
discoveries and I think of discoveries
as sort of apples falling on your head
but those apples only set off good ideas
if someone has prepared your head before
and so it's a very collaborative
activity so I wrote down some of the
things I'm most proud of and one is
something I haven't talked about which
is early in my career when Ted Heath was
Prime Minister Britain and the
government lost control of inflation and
I was young father and I would go to the
store and I thought all individual
relative prices were going up because
there was all this unanticipated
inflation so I predicted that this
unanticipated inflation would actually
increase savings without people wanting
to increase savings and I thought that
was a ridiculous prediction and so did
everyone in the common room at Cambridge
and I was widely laughed at until it
became true and the data of course then
poppers curse starts again strike again
and there are lots of other stories for
why that might be happening but for me
that was the first time in my life that
I came up with a prediction that seemed
ridiculous and turned out to be borne
out in the data I talked a little bit
already about the creating panel data
from a time series of cross-section
which is more a tool than a discovery
but it's helped investigate a wide range
of substantive questions and it's now a
standard technique more by macro than
micro people
I talked about my realization that
popular kinds to the permanent income
hypothesis or self conduct contradictory
and that's again been very productive
and I realized and I think this is
probably the thing that I must pry it
off to this days the work that Chris
Paxton I did realizing that these
various filtering behaviors or
responsive behaviors so that you can
have a driving stochastic process in
which there's completely uncorrelated
risk which nevertheless can drive in
rising inequality I mean something that
I think is very relevant for what we're
going to do today so I'm almost out of
time and I just wanted to end by showing
you some pictures of some of the people
I've collaborated with over the years
there's John Mille bar sitting down
there Gila rock I'm Chris Paxson will be
here tomorrow Martin browning this is
John Campbell this is my friend John
Torres who I work with in India here's
Alan Heston and Betina anton who's
sitting in the front row here and most
recently I've been working on well-being
with Danny Kahneman and Arthur stone and
trying to bridge the sometimes
unbridgeable gaps between economists and
psychologists and then these are people
that I never wrote papers with but whose
work had a really definitive effect on
the shape of my own work there's Richard
stone who really was my mentor who won
the prize in 1984 you can see I've been
imitating his bowtie ever since though I
don't think I've ever dared risk this
combination of stripes that he had there
never mind the black onyx cigarette
holder which was sort of very much a
part of the pattern
- there's Terence Gorman up at the top
here this is the only photograph I could
find I even went to the econometric
society archives and very
characteristically turns Gorman never
turned in his photograph as president of
the econometrics Society so you can find
the president in the year
for and the president the year after but
there's no photograph in the 1973
archives at all
that's Franco Modigliani who find out
that I was working on lifecycle
hypotheses long before I knew enough to
talk to Franco and was completely
overwhelmed the same was true with
Terrence Gorman I mean he always assumed
you knew more than he did which was
terribly bewildering until you got a lot
further along there's Jim Heckman on the
top right there who is again not just in
life cycle work but in many other things
I've done in my life has been quite a
decisive influence that's a march his
son who I haven't really talked about
but his he has been responsible for what
I think of as a lifetime commitment to
thinking ethically about the
implications of my work and trying to
bring some sort of ethical dimension to
economics there's Dan McFadden who with
Terence was one of the early people who
brought duality to demand and there's
Bob Hall on the bottom right who did
this funded work on consumption
functions and changed everything around
so thank with thanks to them and thanks
to you all for listening thank you very
much indeed
here you talk about the interior is
particularly interesting for us on the
committee who have studied this work but
didn't really know all these threads
back in history there was the one detail
that maybe you didn't know maybe you
left it out for the sake of brevity and
that which we discovered when we were
preparing the report on you and that was
that one of the fundamental papers by
John mule Bauer on aggregation was
actually first published as a working
paper in economics here at Stockholm
University in 1976 that's our claim to
fame in this prize so I suppose we give
a warm applause not only Trang's Deaton
but also to those people that he has
mentioned some of whom are actually here
with us today so thank you very much
you